- Well, speaking about your bubble,
is your wife, Deborah Roberts,
doing "Good Morning
America" from there as well.
- Yeah, yeah.
In fact, we,
there've been a number of times,
we've literally been on the same time.
- Oh.
- Like I'm in here and
she's in the living room.
Now that was like when it was colder,
I've now moved out in front of the garage,
but you know--
- She kicked you out
to the garage? (laughs)
It's like, "Today Show's" got the garage.
"Good Morning America's"
got the living room.
(laughs)
- What are you gonna do?
What are you gonna do?
- That's amazing.
That's very kind of you.
- I was looking back at the,
when you were just getting
ready to start the show
and you guys had just bought your ranch.
- Oh, in Montana, yeah.
- So, thank God you did, geez.
- I know, that's where we went.
Yeah, we were there for two months.
Um, yeah.
But Al, do you ever walk behind her
or mess with your wife's shot ever?
Just 'cause, you know, you're competing.
- You know, I have.
There was one point where she
was doing something with Nick
and I wanted to take a picture
and I thought I had the right angle
and all of a sudden I
hear a Robin Roberts go,
"Oh, is that an Al Roker sighting?"
I'm like.
(laughs)
So I decided to just own it.
- Yeah, and you're like,
"Oh, my bad." (laughs)
That's awesome.